I'm very excited my guest tonight has
starred in the social network and the
art of self defense as well as of course
the zombie land movies he can now be
seen in two brand-new movies that were
made available for streaming resistance
and vivarium or vivarium I don't know
he'll correct me instantly please
welcome Jesse Eisenberg Jesse how are
you
vivarium yeah great great great how are
you I'm doing pretty well I'm not sure
where you are what where are you right
now what are you inside it looks like
you're in a bunker yeah no no if only no
it's um I'm in I'm in Lawrence Kansas I
was like in Los Angeles for work then
this happened and we were trying to get
back to Indiana where we live and so we
rented like an RV so that we can kind of
isolate but also get back home I see I
see so yeah you're in an RV and you're
traveling across what sounds like the
Midwest in an RV with your wife and your
son is that right that's right
we're try to get back to Indiana to help
out at my mother-in-law's domestic
violence shelter who are losing their
volunteers because their volunteers are
college students so trying to get back
to help out there and we feel just like
you know totally helpless man that's
well that's very that's very nice of you
to make this effort to go and help out
obviously a great cause I'm gonna be
honest with you the the audio and the
audio and the video we're getting from
you is a pretty is a little sketchy but
um probably because you're in an RV in
Lawrence Kansas I I think it makes for
compelling television and so oh yeah
this is like I read about it do you
think this might be your season finale
this could be my finale finale no these
are grim jokes but it does look like I'm
talking to an astronaut in 1962 that was
one of the that was a great mission I
don't know what your funny about I mean
it was it was when they were just trying
to orbit the most you know
the first time I've been compared to gym
level yes exactly
well it's a fine comparison I've never
lived in an RV before is everything
functioning well in the RV are you okay
it's it's 99.9% perfect so so this is a
car and a house so like a million things
can go wrong and if you have ever had a
car or a house they often do this is
both and there's only one actually one
thing wrong in this entire thing which
is the the the valve for the human waste
is is the one thing that not functioning
well yeah wait yeah the valve that helps
control meaning drain the human right
waste into a receptacle is not working
that's precisely it that's precisely it
are you okay are you a handy fellow are
you able to fix this on your own if
something is going wrong I'm helpful and
immediately relaxed and all of my normal
fantasy worries are gone yeah and I
realize that my life is like just my
life is just completely consumed with
worries that I make up that have no
bearing on the world I see I see I'm
gonna confess something to you because
we've known each time I'm the same way
when everything a common Placid I'm
anxious but when the [ __ ] hits the fan
there's some part of me that thinks oh
I've reached equilibrium this is the
world I deserve to live in and that's
prom yes I think you gave the Freudian
analysis of our issue which is that we
have so much self-criticism or hey [ __ ]
or whatever when in the world is going
and we think yes this is exactly right
Jessie a lot of people are stocking up
or try have tried to stock up on
necessities what have you tried to stock
up on as best you can I mean I we went
to a gas station to buy paper towels and
there were two rolls and I felt so
guilty taking both I just took one and I
came back into the RV my wife said what
the hell you doing yet the other roll of
paper towels I said but what if somebody
else needs them and she said no one's
going to a gas station for paper towels
and I realized that's like a good adage
to have in an otherwise chaotic time so
did you go back and buy the other roll
no because I general so I'm using my
dirty socks to stop up you know puddles
and stuff yeah
well I think that's Noble that you
decided to take both rolls
oh yeah any indulgences that you've
stocked up on yeah I mean I I was trying
to actually before it happened I was
trying to gain weight for a movie and I
was eating a pint of Ben & Jerry's fudge
brownie and I was eating that every
night I'd microwave it for about five
seconds you can't see but I just
referenced where the microwave is and
and I I did fine I found wine at a gas
station so I I ate it that night I
should have reckoned you know please
explain to me you microwave it for five
seconds to get it just a little bit soft
right it's it's it seems it's too it's
too much of a commitment eat a full pint
of frozen ice cream but if it's soft it
just feels like you know chicken soup or
something more yeah multi eaten that way
curious you have made these very
well-known movies these Zombieland
movies about surviving in a situation
somewhat like the one we have now we're
not being chased by zombies but we are
you know battling an invisible foe we're
all ready to take care of ourselves did
you learn anything have any of your
Zombieland skills been useful at all to
you during this pandemic
yeah no no it turns out it turns out
it's just a funny movie yeah just a
funny movie and a late sequel no I mean
you know the only thing like my
character has Purell with him time and
even like set a joke in the first movie
about Purell I don't even know if it was
in the script so if I made the
then I in some way enhance that brand
and now I can't seem to find a Purell
anywhere right and not one rule that
have been helpful is now a practical
impossibility yeah there is no Purell
I bought expensive witch hazel the other
night which turns out is just um it just
tones the skin I thought oh this is
alcohol I can use no no no yes what do
you mean you bought witch hazel why
would you buy witch hazel who said to
buy that I was desperate I had the pint
of ice cream and I thought I need some
hand sanitizer I couldn't find anything
so I I just thought it was Thayer's
brand witch hazel I thought okay
worst-case scenario I'll have better
pours and it turns out there's case
scenarios come through you have terrible
skills terrible yes for survival yes I
know that when my wife is coming in the
RV I'm on the Conan O'Brien show Oh God
we have happened anyway
real life folks I'm sorry sorry my my
wife is Anna my and in in what what am I
lost in this what's the we're we're
dealing these are dark times so you're
allowed to say whatever you want it
sounded to me like your son his hands in
a pipe of [ __ ] your son said in a pipe
in a piper kid and then he just said it
he just repeated me cuz he yes yes yes
okay this is fine this is real life this
is what's happening everyone's coping in
their own way and to recap Jesse
Eisenberg is trapped in an RV with his
wife and son in Lawrence Kansas the
valve that allows him to get rid of the
excrement in the RV yeah malfunctioning
and his son just put his hand into a
pipe of aforementioned [ __ ] is that
right that's it you sound like the
character on like a drama after a
commercial break
we just get this straight-- ponen thing
jesse eisenberg i just think we're I
think we're all handling this in our own
way and we're doing the best we can
well talk about this project which this
is a great time to be watching streaming
movies and you have this movie out
that's actually sort of sounds like it
lines up a little bit with the national
mood at the moment would you say that's
fair yes yes yeah I did this movie if I
am about this kind of young couple that
moves to the suburbs it turns into this
kind of hellscape where they can't get
out of this world they try to burn their
house down it reappears they try to
drive out landing in front of the same
house I realize now in our discussions
that no one's gonna watch this movie as
we discuss it and you know it's like
kind of gets at the cluster phobia that
we're experiencing now but if you want
more of that the movie is an amazing
kind of fever dream of a movie yeah
terrible job promoting it by telling
people that you won't want to see it but
yeah let me help save you in your plug
for the movie which is that yes if you
want to feel if you want to feel some
sort of empathetic mirror of your
current situation how about that yes the
movie health break I think right now is
is huge on streaming everyone's watching
outbreak you'd think that would be the
last movie people would watch so there's
a need a perfect time for your movie
really oh that's interesting I didn't
realize okay if that's what's popular
yes people will love this movie if you
like that other one you'll love this by
Miriam is is one project the other one I
want to mention is resistance this is a
movie about the famous mind Marcel
Marceau who I didn't realize this when
he was a young man was in the resistance
fighting the Germans in France is that
right yeah he started out as kind of
like you know he's a young performer in
France and then he yeah he joined the
French Resistance he ended up saving
like 200
children whose parents were killed
during the war
and kind of developed his mime and
developed his craft as he's doing this
unbelievably heroic thing isn't that
crazy that mime was invented fighting
Germany in World War two make sense in
retrospect because it's such a powerful
art no no well mine wasn't created I
mean you know I'm existed but for Marcel
Marceau who you know I'd say I'm
personified what we think of as mime in
the last you know a half century yeah
you know was kind of perfect his craft
during that time yeah Marcel Marceau was
to mime what I think I am too spoken and
performed comedy okay how's our
connection what's that how's the
connection there was a lag there after I
said what I said I didn't hear an
immediate yes you're right
yeah no it was the connection yeah that
was a problem there was the connection
yeah no you're right you're totally
right yes sir you can shouldn't so like
I'd here in Kansas Kansas no you're
exactly right
I would say like was it um way to
remember the jerk like I like you are
too comedy what Michael Jordan is too
comedy do you - yes I love is that one
of the road yeah it would apply here he
made it listen did you learn any mine
for this movie yes I learned tons of
mine can you show me anything in an RV
over a badly connected zoom session yes
I mean yeah I mean wait so ok wait this
is like a thing that is like kind of
Dave this is a bit 101 this is like but
that you know Marceau would do this and
it would if it looks bad it's the
connection and not my skill set there's
also like Marceau is famous for walking
against the wind do you know this yeah
show me it's walking against the wind in
a crowded RV and yeah once again if it's
not the fault of me it's the fault of
the RV yeah let me see if I could
[Laughter]
yeah V look at me I'm going downstairs
yeah yeah it's a bit awesome powers yeah
so I'm just leaning forwards yeah I
apologize I want you to stay well and I
want you mean make sure I get this out a
vivarium and resistance are both
available on video on demand and digital
right now and these are great projects
and you know what it's a it's a good
time it's a good time to be streaming
and watching some great brand new
content so check that out and Jesse yeah
you're on my short list of people I'd
really love to talk to at this moment
because I admire you
you're a really good guy and I wish you
the best of luck on this trip get that
toilet fixed in the RV and um and and
Happy Trails and and I will see you in
better times thank you so much going
YouTube right take care of Jess thank
you bye bye